you had a lot of contact with Lyndon
Johnson President Lyndon Johnson Lyndon
Johnson used to call you we now have a
president obviously who tweets when he's
unhappy about something that's been
written about him Lyndon Johnson would
actually pick up the phone when he was
president and call you is that right yes
as well as other reporters it was fairly
common for him to call reporters and say
what the hell are you doing to me boy
yeah and give you how to do in the pond
yet to hold the phone away from your ear
Casey did he think because you were from
Texas you should cut him a break or
something he did and I he expressed it
to me several times particularly a
person became White House correspondent
then Johnson was president and one day
he did call me into the office and say
what the hell's wrong with you boy I
mean you're a Texan yeah we have to
stick together
I had no explanation to him about the
independence and importance of freedom
oppression that doesn't count when
you're from you know where you over from
Texas Yeah right what'd I tell you to
write having said all that that Lyndon
Johnson was a dreamer yeah and what he
accomplished in terms of civil rights
legislation in 1960s there will always
be the Vietnam albatross activist memory
but in terms of domestic policy he was
one of the great presidents there is a I
don't know if it's an urban legend or if
it's true but there was a story that
Lyndon Johnson he was a very earthy guy
that very and that he would he was very
comfortable talking to aides and
reporters sometimes in the Oval Office
while using the bathroom while they were
physically there not on the phone but
physically there is that is that it is
that true that is true and I can bear
eyewitness testimony
[Laughter]
would you like to draw it for us
[Laughter]
you